je voudrais associer à ma question mes
collègues Nicolas et députés de l'Allier
de Vichy ou monsieur Fabrice brun député
de l'Ardèche et étend d'autres sur tous
les bancs ma question s'adresse à
Monsieur le Ministre de la santé et de
la prévention et concerne le
remboursement des cures thermales par
l'Assurance Maladie actuellement les
cures thermales sont remboursées à 65%
sur prescription médicale et représente
0,15% des dépenses de l'assurance
maladie la convention qui lit nos
établissements thermaux et l'assurance
maladie arrive à échéance à la fin de
l'année et une nouvelle convention est
actuellement en cours de négociation
pour entrer en vigueur au 1er janvier
2023 or certains ici même évoquent un
éventuel déremboursements et remettant
cause l'efficacité même des cures
thermales il y aurait là un triple
risque un risque économique avec 600 000
curistes sur la France entière et 500
millions d'euros de chiffre d'affaires
pour une centaine de stations normal un
risque territorial puisque 70% de ces
stations ont moins de 5000 habitants et
sont situés dans les territoires ruraux
des territoires ruraux déjà fragilisés
après deux ans de covid et puis un
risque pour nos patients sécurisent ce
soigne avec un service médical rendu
évalué notamment avec les experts
désignés par votre ministère et l'Agence
française pour la recherche thermale
avec des diminutions de journées
d'hospitalisation des diminutions de
consommation médicamenteuses alors
monsieur le ministre pour nos patients
pour nos territoires et de vous
favorables au maintien du remboursement
des